am 29 märz präsentierte bundesminister
rossi die mannes ausrüstung die im zuge
der beschaffungs offensive den
soldatinnen und soldaten zur verfügung
gestellt werden wird das was wir heute
hier präsentieren ist die persönliche
schutzausrüstung ist die persönliche
ausrüstung der soldaten ist die
bewaffnung die sich in den ein oder
anderen segment erneuern wird
aber ich glaube das ist unsere
verantwortung des hauses dass jene die
im einsatz stehen dass jene die für
sicherheit täglich sorgen sei es im
inlands einsatzzeit im auslandseinsatz
dass wir diesen soldaten auch
bestmögliche ausrüstung zur verfügung
stellen wenn es auch um die persönlichen
schutz geht
[Musik]
ein